the migrants call this a special kind of
hell
a hell where no one can hear you crying
those here have disappeared to the
outside world there's room after room
packed full and many have been here for
months
they complain of being beaten and fed
little with no medical swimming every
day every day nobody to head for Matt my
leg there are several unexplained
injuries but officials stand over us
during our entire visit the gods speak
little English so a few migrants grab at
the chance to tell us what's happening
are you going to get in problems with
these people who are listening yeah you
will get into problem what do you think
will happen to you when when we go just
did that I don't know how to say what
did they use to think there what did
they use do they beat with their hands
right away by fight one
always be brief they pray for a release
from this unrelenting misery Libya was
only meant to be a staging post on route
to a new life in Europe now they're
stuck with no one wanting them in
Tripoli where the authorities are
struggling to pay the center's guards
what do what is the reason for the
beating you just beat you any any time
this is what do they use to be have you
been beaten have you been
in another detention center in the
Capitol there are more claims of
brutality we've been asked not to film
the guards but many of them are watching
from behind the camera no well he's
showing me wheels on his front and on
his back which he says where he says
he's been whipped by the guards he's
talking to us now they're receiving
threats from the guards none of whom
speak English the claims of brutality
are robustly denied by those in charge
of the West
illegal immigration all our places that
honored none of the governor's would
accept any bad treatment against any
detainee torture and beatings are just
not acceptable and all these claims that
you have made will be looked into
seriously and investigated to stop any
of this happening there are children
among those locked up two year old NAT
whose mother died crossing the Sahara to
get to Libya
his father is desperate so desperate he
wants to give his only son to me the
fellow detainee who's helping us
translate is equally incredulous but
explains the father just wants someone
anyone to help his child and take him
away from this prison I understand I
can't take his children I can't take his
child
explain to him oh I don't know what I
couldn't do but it's just not possible
for me to take his baby another
heartbreaking dilemma in a Libya now
fraught with them
Alex Crawford Sky News Tripoli